[Applause]
thank you very much and it's a great
pleasure and honor that I've been
invited here tonight there is a famous
famous Jewish saying that words should
be weighed not counted there are no
speeches that we can give no words of
comfort or solace we can offer that can
never take away the pain of what
happened in hallow on Yom Kippur
today we honor those young victims who
got killed while simply living their
lives in front of the local synagogue we
stand together with our families and
their loved ones as they go through
trauma which no one should ever have to
we thank the heroes who protected others
who showed us that faced with evil
humanity is capable of good but today we
cannot help thinking of the fear the
fear of all the victims and witnesses
like you Anastacia
the fear of the Jewish congregation
inside the synagogue and we think of the
fear that every Jewish person in Europe
felt in that moment that heart-sinking
fear that Europe's Jewish community
knows all too well that fear which comes
back stronger after every anti-semitic
attack that is reported on the news from
the Brussels meeting you Jewish Museum
we just saw in the film - the kosher
supermarket in Paris from the Jewish
school in Toulouse to the synagogue in
hallow and in the last days alone we
have seen Bobby beaten up on the streets
of London
and the Jewish cemeteries vandalized in
via time for every one of those
incidents we see in the news there are
many more which happen every single day
across our Union they may be smaller and
less violent in nature but they are real
and they are on the rise and they create
an atmosphere in which Jews no longer
feel safe and start doubting the future
in Europe ladies and gentlemen these
attacks because small our attacks on the
Jewish community but their consequences
and their repercussions are attacks on
all of us on our way of life our values
of Tolerance our unity in diversity
anti-semitism is a poison for our
community and it is up to all to fight
it to prevent it and to eradicate it the
fight against anti-semitism is as much
for every other part of our community as
it is for Jewish people and it is one
which must be led at local regional
national and European level we must all
do our part the Jewish community is not
alone this is the message I will take
with me to Yad Vashem in Jerusalem in
January we will lead this fight together
we will build on the work done in the
last years in the Commission in the
Parliament and in the Member States but
as rising challenge needs a stronger
response from outside indeed as you
mentioned I haven't
that my vice pretty the president
margaritas kinas to lead the fight
against anti-semitism and today I can
announce that he will be supported by a
new dedicated team with very experienced
people who will work with our
coordinator for combating anti-semitism
and for fostering Jewish life and
fostering Jewish life is something which
I've always taken very seriously as
Minister of Defense I decided to
reintroduce after 100 years hobbies as
chaplains in the Bundeswehr the armed
forces together with Christian priests
this is as important for Jewish soldiers
as it is for the rest of the armed
forces it is a way to learn about the
different cultures that together build a
common European culture and it is a way
to understand one another to understand
that in our diversity of backgrounds we
are all part of the same community there
would be no European culture without
Jewish culture and there would be no
Europe without Jewish people we will
remain vigilant and more we will act at
all levels through security means of
course but also in our education system
and in the public debate there is one
fundamental freedom that we Europeans
must reclaim and that is the freedom
from fear whatever they believe in thank
you so much
[Applause]